des kilomètres et des kilomètres de
côtes pour les municipalités
gaspésiennes niché au bord du littoral
c'est un peu leur colonne vertébrale
car la proximité avec la mer a longtemps
rimé avec prospérité mais le vent
pourrait tourner puis 6 nous sommes à
sainte anne des monts pour le maire
simon des chaînes et son équipe la
gestion de l'érosion côtière ce n'est
rien de nouveau mais avec le dérèglement
climatique
la tâche est devenue colossale on nage à
contre-courant c'est difficile il n'y a
pas une séance du conseil encore hier
soir qu'un citoyen le rouge on côtière
je veux les roches
si je mets des roches à un endroit il
faut que je le fasse pour tout le monde
j'ai pas capable d'ouvrir cette porte au
seul
sait que l'eau du fleuve saint-laurent
se réchauffe faisant augmenter le volume
d'eau et disparaître le couvert de glace
en hiver
laissant les comptes toute nue devant
des tempêtes et des vagues féroce les
scientifiques estiment qu'à certains
endroits le littoral pourrait perdre
plusieurs mètres d'ici la fin du siècle
ce matin le maire a rendez vous avec
kevin pelti le propriétaire du motel
restaurant manoir sûrement
le merle informe qu'il n'a pas pu
autoriser ces plans d'agrandissement
nous on est complet quand même quelques
mois d'av ans pour la période de la
saint jean jusqu'à la fin du travail
puis l'on s'est dit massa serait
peut-être le moment de pouvoir agrandir
l'entreprise va bien puis finalement
mais ça on n'a pas eu les autorisations
ne pollue le droit de le faire
c'est que la ville doit appliquer la
nouvelle réglementation provinciale né à
l'érosion et la protection des berges
qui est très contraignante
l'entrepreneur est en plus laissé à
lui-même pour protéger l'intégrité de
son terrain qui se fait grignoter de
plus en plus par la main alors toute
cette portion le graviton
exactement s'étaient perdus au complet
puis les marches qu'on a ici le c'était
presque cinq pieds le plus bas fallait
monter dans nos marche pour voir
descendre l'autre côté donc c'est après
ça que le muret de béton est arrivé un
muret pour y asseoir chaque hiver
d'énormes blocs de béton un ouvrage de
près de 100 mille dollars qu'il a dû
payer seule saison j'aimerais ça pouvoir
rêver j'aimerais ça pouvoir viser grand
cette année c'est sous du découragement
par rapport à tout ça l'élu s'est donné
comme mission d'accompagner citoyens et
entrepreneurs qui vivent des problèmes
liés à l'érosion il veut à tout prix
éviter que sa ville se vide surtout que
selon l' indice de vitalité des mrc la
mrc de la haute gaspésie dont fait
partie civile se classe bonne dernière
sur les 104
le maire va aussi à la rencontre d'un
propriétaire d'un bloc appartement de 7
logements c'est recruter a découvert que
son immeuble était non conforme au
zonage actuel il est donc incapable de
le vendre depuis juin 2021
c'est une zone
inondable donc sabords pratiquement
jusqu'à la 1re avenue donc c était
impossible de faire des changements à
partir de ce moment
pour être conforme il aurait dû
condamner cinq des sept logements son
investissement par theo van une
situation absurde selon le maire
d'autant plus que la ville vit une
pénurie de logements l'élu vient lui
annoncer qu'après avoir fait des pieds
et des mains le conseil a finalement
trouvé une façon de régulariser son
dossier jean loubat 9
greffière sont à la table pour trouver
une solution mais s'il peut compter sur
une oreille attentive au conseil
municipal
lorsqu'ils interpellent les niveaux de
gouvernements supérieurs il a
l'impression de parler dans le vide
parce que les instances du mental les
décideurs ont ont baissé les bras et le
problème est trop bas on dirait que le
poste à cazaux c'est un problème
généralisé ça va être trop d'argent des
situations complexes et exténuante trop
nombreuses pour la municipalité de 6500
résidents selon mr d'autant plus que la
ville est aussi responsable de ses 17
kilomètres de routes municipales sur la
côte
le maire croit que les gouvernements
sont déconnectés de la réalité donc moi
j'ai des infrastructures égouts aqueduc
en bordure de la route qui ferait sur le
bord de la mer
si on n'a pas cette vision à long terme
pour lutter contre les changements
climatiques contre l'érosion côtière qui
va s'occuper de mes infrastructures qui
vont tomber en gondole faut me laisser
tenter de réparer ça aux frais des
contribuables c'est impensable d'y
parvenir seul le ministère des
transports du québec et responsable de
protéger syrie et prépare une étude
d'impact pour 2024 qui permettra ensuite
d'élaborer un plan d'action trop peu
trop tard selon maire qui déplore en
plus d'être exclue la réflexion qui on
nous dit gouvernement de proximité alors
on nous laisse la responsabilité puis on
nage dans ça mais c'est pas nous qui
avons la législation entre les mains
donc on fait quoi pour y parvenir ça
devient excessivement difficile et
demandé aux gaspésiens de s'éloigner de
la mer c'est aussi s'attaquer à leur
identité culturelle car l'eau salée
coule dans leurs veines le fleuve la
mère fait partie de notre adn
il faut pas exproprier les gens à
l'extérieur parce que la mère fait
partie de nous